[Applause]
welcome back to down the middle today we
have with us
our third guest in a very long drawn out
series to help understand the plumbing
of the financial system
the interaction between the federal
reserve and the treasury department
where we are in the economic cycle
and where we're headed in terms of
dollar funding which is obviously become
so much more important with the
situation in russia and ukraine because
it's it's it's cast a light on it so we
have with us today david beckworth he is
a senior research fellow at the mercatus
center at george mason university
what's interesting to me former
international economist at the u.s
department of treasury so i don't
normally speak with former treasury
officials i speak with a lot more fed
officials
and he's the author of boom and bust
banking the causes and cures
of the great recession which is
something we can talk about uh but first
let's do what we always do on down the
middle
welcome and let's find out who you are
so it's great great to have you well
thank you for having me on your show
um
david walk us through
the path that that took you to where you
are your influences
where you grew up who inspired you uh
mentors your studies what what your
takeaways were
as you were growing up that put you on
the path that led you to where you are
today okay well we could do a whole show
on that i'm sure but we'll keep this
short um
so my parents were actually missionaries
in africa for a number of years
and i was a young a young person then
and i think that really
sparked my curiosity because then i came
back to the states and i saw the stark
difference between how people lived in
africa and how they lived in the us
and that as an elementary school kid i
was
asking the question why why is it so
different and you know like most
american kids i got caught up in the
things of life sports
popular culture but in the back of my
mind that question was always lurking
and i was thinking about it and then in
college i finally took some economics
courses that for me provided a
systematic framework for thinking about
those issues which i had never seen
before
and although my initial interest was
more on the development side of
economics i took macro economics the
principles the first course and it
really sparked my interest and i wasn't
an economics major at the time but i
really loved it it never dawned on me
that you could actually be an economist
as a career
this wasn't on my radar
i don't think i've ever heard anybody
say that
yeah
well it just you know i came from a
world where you know those type of
career options just weren't on anyone's
radar so and even i i i got my
undergraduate degree
and then i went to work on an mba and i
had to take some more economics classes
of course and then it clicked i was like
and i love that as a college student let
me take some now and finally i went on
to get a phd but things that kind of
helped click and really crystallize that
that interest you know i hate to to say
this but there are several people during
this time i was reading this is in the
mid to late 90s
um who who made me even more interested
one was paul krugman back when he wrote
good economics
he had a book called pop
internationalism where he went after all
these crazy ideas on trade theory and
and kind of more against the populist
strains of that time and it has made so
much sense the way he was arguing
against
um what today would be popular you know
nationalist kind of views of trade um
and then also there was a book i read
called the secrets of the temple oh gosh
yes
you know that so that's that was a page
turner written by a journalist now that
book again came from left to center i
tend to be more writer's center in my
views but it was a very captivating read
of course he's very much the author is
very much coming from a labor
perspective you know paul walker really
screwed over labor destroyed the economy
of course i read that book and i was
like what a hero
he made the tough choices you know not
to be clear there was a lot of human
suffering that went on but of course um
but i my view is he definitely was the
person for that time so reading that and
finally on one last person i'll mention
um i went to the university of georgia
for graduate school just wasn't based on
you know looking at rankings just it's
close to home i like football so i went
there go dogs and lo and behold who was
there as a professor in the economics
department george seljun
so
george seldon was my teacher he was my
dissertation chair and now we often work
together we collaborate um but he was
pivotal in kind of shaping my thinking
about the fed
about nominal gdp targeting about you
know keeping the fed's footprint really
light um so that's my story in brief
keeping the fed's footprint really light
um
so
let's um
let's focus on the the powell era so his
first day in office i'm sure you
remember the maybe maybe you don't the
stock market fell more than a thousand
points the dow jones industrials
declined more than a thousand points
not a peep out of him didn't say a word
you know his first congressional
testimony he was very staunch and
adamant you know it is not the fed's job
to backstop the stock market well the
stock market didn't like him saying that
one bit uh but he was definitely
kind of the the 2012 version of jay
powell you know
the not phd the not academic so to speak
more of the
more more of the the markets person in
him the former private equity
this is the man who uh this is the man
who orchestrated solomon brothers when
it blew up and worked with warren
buffett to do so when he was when he was
at the treasury department
uh so a bit of a different character a
little bit more paul volcker in the
beginning
and
and then maybe you can take us through
what happened is 2018 progressed because
as i often
reminisce that the debt of general
electric was downgraded on halloween of
that year
and that set off a daisy chain of events
that culminated in what we know as the
powell pivot so
walk us through 2018 because one of your
i'm going to end with one of your more
recent tweets but that's where we're
headed but walk us through what happened
in 2018 first so my hot take on that
period
was that that was a continuation of the
desire to normalize monetary policy i
mean started with janet yellen i mean
they tried starting back in 2015 they
got one rate hike
but they had to pace themselves they
realized you know they were it was a
very delicate situation i think life was
more complicated than simply pushing
rates back up to where they had been pre
um
great financial crisis and i think jay
pal kind of came into that same mindset
he was going to finish the work that
jenna ellen had started
and so
it was pretty surprising to me actually
to hear them in in 2018 i believe you
probably know that the timing of this
better but i recall in 2018 they were
very much talking up rate hikes multiple
rate hikes to the extent they were
willing to have an inverted yield curve
and several of them even said so
outright i mean john williams leo
brainerd they all said look it's what we
got to do it's not it's not a big deal
this time is different they've been
booked that you know
so then comes around you know we see
what happens early 2019 things get a
little volatile financial markets don't
like what they're seeing and yeah pal
pivots pretty quickly
um also during this time something else
is going on
kind of lurking in the background but
informing this is their view of what is
the
sustainable rate of unemployment the
natural rate of unemployment changes it
it drifts down as they see the
unemployment rate dropping and inflation
not going up you know they're thinking
that through philips curve view of
inflation that's not my preferred
approach but that's the way they think
and they're linking unemployment rate to
inflation and that they're seeing
nothing nothing to happen really with
inflation they keep lowering that they
also keep lowering their long run
terminal value of the federal funds rate
or the they would call r star the
neutral rate so i think all those things
are going into play and
sometime around then i know jay powell
comes out and says yeah we got our our
star wrong we got our u-star wrong um
and and said look you know we definitely
thought the economy was going to heat up
before it did so i think between what
happened in financial markets and
they're re-evaluating
the speed limit of the economy
it made it easy to do the pal pivot and
so
that seemed like it initially
kind of put a band-aid on the situation
in in 2019 in in some ways if you can
look past kind of the flash crash and
the flash recession that of covet really
markets haven't looked back since
in a way if you if you look at it the
2018 episode looks a lot uglier because
it's a little bit more prolonged than
what happened in the immediate aftermath
of the pandemic uh but but something
started to break in
in 2019
it culminated on my birthday that year
it was like set my birthday september
17th it was like september the 16th
that uh that we started to hear a lot of
information out of the new york fed
uh and this is kind of when we walked
into the not qe moment
so what was going on in in funding
markets at the time well
again i'll approach this from a monetary
policies perspective sure um i'm sure
there's a there's a market perspective
but the way i look at it is related to
what the fed was doing with its
operating system so it it switched from
what we call a corridor system with very
few reserves to an ample reserve system
or floor system
and the idea is you you
basically
stop the banking system so full of
reserves that they have an ample amount
and they always will
and and you want to do that so that
you've saturated them you got you got to
the point that whatever you give give
them in terms of reserves they will hold
now the the fed and let me step back the
arguments for doing why why did they do
that well it
implicitly they made a switch in 2000
late 2008 when they went to qe
and they started paying interest on
excess reserves but they officially made
a change i believe early 2019 or 2018
this this ample reserve or floor system
and so this change was had been in place
it required a larger fed balance sheet
but the fed made this statement they
wanted a larger balance sheet so banks
would have ample preserves but they also
wanted it as small as possible ample but
small as possible so there's some
tension there yeah
they wanted to shrink it so they were
doing qt as you know quantitative
tightening shrinking the balance sheet
and so the way i i kind of look at what
happened in september 2019 is they were
shrinking the balance sheet but at the
same time there was also
just a perfect storm of things coming
together um
the
treasury was getting a bunch of
corporate tax receipts
um a bunch of other kind of government
funding was coming in and what happens
is when the government treasury gets
money on its account at the fed the tga
account it takes reserves out of the
banking system so what happened is
the fed accidentally it tripped or fell
back into what we call a corridor system
even though the balance sheet was still
large
it got to the place where reserves were
scarce so
another way of saying is the corridor
system reserves are scarce relative to
demand for them in an ample reserve
system floor system they're abundant and
there's excess and even though the
balance sheet was bigger and it's kind
of hard to wrap our minds around this
they had it had shrunk back because of
all these things going on to a scarce
reserve even though you know it was
still
several trillion dollars it was it was
you know it was at a point where there
wasn't enough reserves to meet demand
and this is tied into things in the repo
market as well
and
which was shocking to the fed it was
shocking to me shocking to everybody
that you know that huge of a balance
sheet wasn't big enough and i can get
into possibly why that's the case well
yeah yeah i mean
if i could interrupt for a second would
you also speak to
negative interest rates abroad and
increasing currency and circulation and
foreign central banks looking to park
money at the fed at the same time that
you've got the balance sheet roll off
quantitative tightening going on so
there were major
exogenous influences on reserves that
were taking place that were not really
in the fed's control i mean you can't
control people desiring to hold currency
in circulation
yeah all those things are happening too
so that's a good point they're they're
they're developing the fed can't control
currency demand directly it um it can't
control foreign demand for
for for you know cash so the all those
things you're right all those it's a
that's why i would call it a perfect
storm and the other thing again i think
it's
hugely important during this time is the
treasury's tga count treasury general
account the fed
and it's huge it's it it you know it
goes above a trillion dollars and that's
a huge swing and then it quickly goes
down whenever you have these you know
debt ceiling talks you know the treasury
will fund up then it runs it down
and it makes makes these big swings and
the amount of reserves and the thing is
that it's hard for the fed to
predict now i had a former colleague
who's with us for about a year chris
russo who actually worked at the new
york fed and his job was to forecast the
treasury general account
part of the fed's balance sheet and he
said it was incredibly hard you know i
mean you you had some sense because you
knew there was a
a debt ceiling limit coming up but the
treasury could swing that thing one way
or the other
driven by politics and the fed he was
kind of guessing now before 2008 under
the previous operating system it was
always much smaller the treasury also
used to keep most of its its cash its
money in the banking system
but once we went to this new floor
system and
interest on reserves began to pay a fair
amount to banks it was actually cheaper
but the treasury would actually make
more money parking it at the fed than in
the banking system because banks would
get
short story is banks would get payments
from the feds fed would give less back
to the treasury treasury would have less
earnings so the treasury realized it
made sense to park those funds have to
fed and save themselves like they lost
revenue from the fed any event i think
the tga is a big part of that but all
this goes back to the change in the
fed's operating system and there's a lot
of other problems about it we can get
into but i think it's a key part of the
story they accidentally fell back into a
scarce reserve system
um daryl duffy has a paper i forget its
name but but it basically makes this
point that
they had a world of
of
uh scarce reserves results of the demand
during this time
and the fed did not mean to be there so
they quickly as you know reverse course
and just kind of
you could argue kick the can down the
road
um for a later moment well they
certainly uh at the moment at least and
we're gonna we're gonna wait to get the
t-shirt because i'm loving the t-shirt
but they certainly uninverted the yield
curve
with not qe and that was i i try and
explain to people
that they can't look at
at the at the not qe era through a
traditional conventional prism because
the fed forcibly uninverted the yield
curve it wasn't something that happened
naturally because of the macroeconomic
backdrop it was it was very mechanistic
in nature and i think that that's a
critical distinction at that point it
was a very fragile juncture
yeah
yeah for sure and you know the fed now
has the standing repo facility
which might hope that's right that's
right there those are my next questions
okay well it's you know given where we
are i mean there's no perfect world i
would love a world where the fed's
balance sheet was much smaller i mean
just for comparison look north to canada
they've had a corridor operating system
a much smaller balance sheet now i
haven't checked up on them recently
because they did expand it during the
pandemic
but during the great financial crisis
2007 2009 they expanded their balance
sheet but they shrunk it back down
and and they have much better interest
rate control i mean one of the reasons
going to a floor ample reserve system is
the argument is that it would provide
better interest rate control if banks
have ample reserves then the fed doesn't
new york play doesn't have to try to
guess how many reserves to put in pull
out it's just it's all taken care of um
but while we found that's not the case i
mean september 2019 is a great example
of that
but meanwhile bank of canada seems doing
a great job with few far reserves but
standing repo facility yeah that that's
a development that i'm hopeful
will
help alleviate some of the pressures we
saw in 2019 should they emerge again
although
i'm a little bit disappointed in its
uptake um
so bill nelson who used to work at the
board of governors had a
talk about this a conference and and
several
banks mentioned they're simply not
interested in participating in this this
facility so you're seeing the headlines
cross you know zero bids i'm like well
zero is a nice round number
yeah i know it is i mean so
in order to make this work and just be
clean you step back the standing repo
facility you can view it as an extension
of the discount window at the fed it's a
way for banks to
swap treasuries for reserves or reserves
for treasuries um as well as primary
dealers are automatically signed up but
banks depository institutions they also
can apply but i believe there's only
been three
two or three that have actually signed
up
and
the problem is if if banks don't start
using it in normal times
then in panic times it's going to be
seen as the same thing as a discount
window of use it's it's you're going to
use the standard facility because you're
in trouble there will be a stigma
yeah yeah so bill nelson says we really
need to get the fed to encourage its use
now make you know and part of it goes to
bank regulators and and bank supervisors
you know if you use standing repo
facility you have to
justify it
um and so it really you need direction
from the top you need the federal
reserve regulators at the top to really
stress and emphasize this is this should
be viewed as a normal part of business
use of standard facility and we haven't
seen that yet so
my hopes may not be realized the next
time we have a crisis unless things
change dramatically well i mean you know
it's interesting you say that because
if you're looking from the outside in
you're like oh they they've got a fix
for that
we're not going to have the treasury
freeze in overnight trading in asia and
like there's no bid on the long bond
um but but
when you equated it to the discount
window all of a sudden a light bulb went
off over my head so that was the best
thing you've done and i immediately said
stigma i mean it's like it's like and
it's reflexive and that i mean yeah i
was i was inside the fed for nine years
during the crisis and we watched that
window and boy banks just didn't want to
go there because it was you might as
well just wave the white flag and say
we're over we're finished so um
reverse repo facility
it's it's seemingly uh there's obviously
no stigma attached to it not that there
would be but maybe you can talk about
that a little bit because
theoretically it's the two working in
conjunction with one another that really
gives the fed control
of yeah of
its range there's multiple angles on
this so let's go to the one you just
mentioned interest rate control i mean
the fact that they have to resort to
this speaks to the problem that industry
control isn't working too well with with
you know the other tools so they had you
know you're right they have a discount
window at the top
in theory anderson reserve should be the
floor the bottom but rates were dropping
below that so they had to turn on the
overnight repo facility again and use it
extensively again
um so it it speaks to the problem
it's more than just the fed itself i
want to be fair i'm blaming the floor
system a lot but it has a lot to do with
regulations as well so i mean it's we
have you know since dodd-frank came out
and basel three there's a lot of
complicated requirements for banks
um and that again that speaks to the
importance of having good top-down you
know leadership
um which speaks to who we have appointed
advice share another another topic but
that that is i think
a big deal um going forward now another
angle in the overnight reverse repo
facility
um
you know when we think about qe or large
scholastic purchases you know i often
will first think about okay what's the
effect on asset prices it is it changing
spreads is it making you know stock
prices go up is it making bond yields
change that's on the asset side of the
fed's balance sheet that that mix is
affecting market prices but there's also
a liability side of the fed's balance
sheet how is the fed funding those asset
purchases and you can think of the fed
as you know relying upon you know
financial intermediary starting with
banks so banks you know their reserves
are parked at the fed those reserves are
funding those asset purchases so now the
fed's liable you know fed has all those
reserves that's liable to the banks but
at some point bank balance sheet
capacity ran out banks could no longer
keep up with especially the
large amount of ls ap the qe that we did
during the pandemic so then
um you know the fed had to turn to money
market funds money market funds had to
provide you know
funding to the fed to get those large
scholastic purchases
and that probably was going to run out
as well soon soon so at some point if if
you keep increasing the fed's balance
sheet to qe the large scholastic
purchases you got to find funding and as
you run out of one funding source you go
to another so one way to look at the
overnight reverse repo facility it was
you know the next funding source the fed
was using um
another angle on the overnight reverse
repo facility is simply you know the fed
is stopping
liquidity into the financial system
banks don't want to hold it at some
point they're saturated by by either you
know demand and or by regulatory reasons
right
liquidity
i i don't think people under understand
very well the regulatory constraints
on banks when it comes to i mean i
understand what you're saying when
you're saying
their balance sheet hit capacity but can
you unpack that a tiny bit just in case
people are less familiar
so
there's a number of regulations again
that come out of like dodd-frank and
basel three that require banks to have
hold so much capital starting to hold
the fund with so much capital it's a
proper way to say that
they don't hold capital they fund with
capital but in the event
so for example the supplemental leverage
ratio
um is one that one that was in the
headlines in the news
and it looks it's a leverage ratio and
that leverage ratio
is supposed to be a backup to the first
capital ratio which is risk based so
banks use risk based weighting you know
do they have they put enough capital the
problem with risk
based funding is you know banks can can
gain it they can you know buy certain
assets so the leverage ratio which is
it's supposed to be a way to make sure
banks are funding with a certain amount
of capital if they fall through the
first
you know rules they got the second one
the problem is it looks at all the
assets on the fed's balance sheet so it
looks at you know looks like
equity relative to to our capital
relative to the amount of assets and
when you include reserves as part of the
bank's assets so that your equity has to
be a certain percent of all your assets
and you have a lot of reserves and
particularly during you know pandemic or
great recession reserves become a big
big big part of the bank's balance sheet
and this rule and others like it if
you're in fact if you're a big
you know globally important bank there's
something called the e
slr which is an added requirement on top
of the existing one but the bottom line
is this
the more reserves you park on your
balance sheet as an asset the more
equity or capital funding you've got to
have and so at some point banks are like
well you know we're not we can't expend
our balance sheet anymore it's getting
too costly it's just too much
so those regulations really didn't
impair
banks balance sheets so you know jumping
ahead briefly to march 2020
many parts of that story but one of the
stories is banks could not intermediate
the you know the increased demand
for liquidity during that period because
they have these rules and regulations
same thing you know before then but the
overnight reverse repo facility is part
is tied to this in the sense that banks
could only
absorb depending on the locus absorbed
so much liquidity from the fed or
alternatively could only fund so much of
the fed's purchases
and in part because of these regulations
and then kind of fell on money market
funds to step in and try to pick up the
difference
uh
there's a future uh there is a basel for
in the works if i if i understand
correctly
and and what would are you familiar with
that
i
not much more than you i've heard about
it i'm not sure what they're trying to
do but
uh yeah i mean i i think i mean it means
well i mean the idea is to have
standardized you know approach
um
with that said i i was again talking to
this gentleman bill nelson he mentioned
that the basel iii requirement for the
supplemental leverage ratio is actually
lower the global standard is actually
lower than what is in the u.s
so the u.s actually has
relatively tight standards and as you
know
right now there's
the fed is taking comments and reviewing
a change to supplemental leverage ratio
so that reserves are not a part of it in
fact as you know during the
during the um actual pandemic
the fed relaxed that
and what we saw so in other words banks
didn't have to worry about having enough
you know capital to cover those added
assets in terms of reserves when that
temporary rule ended
that's when we saw balance sheet space
shrink
and the sudden growth and overnight
reverse repo so the supplemental
leverage ratio is tied closely to the
overnight you know repurchase facility
so there is this link going on so it's
it's amazing how important not only is
the plumbing of the system but the
regulations on banks balance sheets that
surround you know this activity
um
so
you tweeted out i think a few days ago
this time is different than 2018 2019
which in hindsight
was an unforced error from which the fed
quickly pivoted
this time their hands are tied with
inflation
so what what were you saying there
well i was being snarky to be honest i
i have a t-shirt i made actually in 2018
2019 i i i took the emblem of the fed
probably copyrighted but you know you
can go to a t-shirt web web page and
create your own t-shirt so i put the fed
seal on the t-shirt in the middle then i
have the motto for the fed 2018-2019 and
the motto was we have the nerve to
invert the curve
this one day that hit me was like ah
that's a great little rhyme and that's
what they're and that again that's why
they were talking up in 28 late 2018
um and so the unforced error was that
they were you know
talking up rate hikes which was leading
this inversion and then they reversed
and they back then they had the
flexibility to do that but this time i
don't see
how they can
make that same pivot
and and address inflation at the same
time they're kind of in a corner right
now but yeah so now i'm just saying look
if the fed
needs to address it for inflation
they're behind the curve
to be fair i'm behind the curve too i
didn't expect inflation to last this
long
but
yeah it's going to be a tough balancing
act for them to get
through this next year
so um
when we talk i mean
24 7 my twitter feed is full of the
yield curve debate
and which is important of course
janet yellen will tell you most most
will tell you that it's the three-month
tenure but
there's something that's very uh
there's something that's very mechanical
about that because
the fed controls the three-month rate so
until they raise interest rates there's
no way to invert that curve
so
what is the best yield curve to follow
in your view
oh man
that's a tough question
i know there's been a lot of
work done and emphasis on the shorter
end of the yield curve so
you know something between now and and
you know short term rate maybe a month
two months out and say
two years out
if you look at that
we're a long ways from inverting so it's
actually it's actually going up if you
look at you know so that we know the
two-year treasury yields way way high
right and the fed has yet to raise
meaningfully raised the really short end
and if you look at that yield curve
it looks great but if you take the
longer one then yeah it is a problem
um
i'm not i'm going to claim some
ignorance here i will tell you that a
theory that i think makes sense
and maybe it makes less sense going
forward but you know the the one of the
stories for the yield curve let me step
back there's a debate about the yield
curve is the yield curve merely a
symptom
of a recession that's coming or does it
actually cause a recession and i'd say
it's probably a bit of both but let me
tell the causal story the causal story
is that
banks and other you know financial
intermediaries they depend on a spread
right they depend on funding at a low
cost
and then giving loans or investing at a
higher return higher interest rate
and if to the extent the fed flattens
that and again it's not just the fed i
mean markets on the long end player role
but the fed players roll the short end
but to the extent you know the fed
shrinks that spread it makes it less
profitable to make loans to provide
credit to the economy
and that therefore slows economic
activity so there is an intermediation
story now
and there's some evidence that says this
is still an important channel but
the flip side of this is banks make
money a lot of other ways as well
there's lots of other fees and ways but
kind of the core you know
causal story is
inverting a yield curve makes banks less
profitable which means less credit which
means the slowdown on economic activity
well you know it's it's it's it's
interesting because if you look at that
channel not through the prism of the the
banking system but you're just just in
the prism of of yields in general and
there's a trillion dollars in
non-financial global debt that has to be
refinanced in 2022 so in the current
year
but right now your yield to maturity
across the curve makes it to where if
you're coming to refund refinance and
you're a company to the capital markets
you're going to pay up
you're going to pay more than what
you're rolling over and that's that's a
shift
that's a good point yeah so it has even
greater repercussions than just the
banking system so
yeah and again it just reiterates the
the
point that the fed is in a really tough
spot right now
you know it's it's tightening financial
conditions but it's
also trying to deal with inflation
and i you know to be fair this speaks to
why it probably should have started
earlier it would have been easier maybe
to start late last year but again i want
to be fair i i didn't at the time i was
you know like oh let's just be cautious
so i i'm guilty as charged you know
throw me in with them so i mean
and you know if i could go back in time
i would definitely change my view then
um i have i could say that about a lot
of instances in my life as well so we're
in the same boat um
what what are your kind of favorite
macroeconomic
indicators that you watch that you find
to be the most prescient the most
leading
uh
just on a very basic basic put your put
your macroeconomics 101 hat back on and
what what kind of guides you're thinking
about where the economy is headed well i
look at like long-term interest rates
treasuries
um
and that usually gives me a sense of
they're not entirely related to growth
but they're definitely related to
outlooks um and so a number of things
real growth for inflation expectations
um i particularly like in terms of
inflation expectations i like the
five-year five-year forward
measure
and in my story for this and i was
recently criticized on twitter for it
but i'll tell you my story for it
is that
if we think of
what macroeconomic policy can do both
monetary policy and fiscal policy what
can it control it can control the trend
path of inflation so yes the fed can't
change shipping lanes in china or
you know cure the coronavirus but it can
affect the trend growth of inflation so
supply shocks do affect inflation but
they tend to at some point you know fade
but what does stay with this is the
growth of government debt government
liabilities
and you know the fed and treasury both
play a part in that and if that trend
path is expected to get higher so the
growth rate of the price level going to
go up
we would see it in a five-year five-year
ford now that's a long ways out but at
five years out
presumably all the supply shocks have
faded their role in inflation is gone
and so if that thing starts to go up
then we know you know the market thinks
the feds lost control or they expect
runaway deficits at an unsustainable
level
and so i look at that and right now i
take some comfort in it now to be fair
the markets could be wrong you know they
might get the forecast wrong
i don't get so worked up about like
shorter term like break-evens because
they do follow oil closely and other
supply shocks but i think that so that's
one of my major
measures i've been looking at lately
the other one i'll pitch just because
it's who i am
is i like
looking at nominal gdp
and in particular i i look at a measure
not just the number itself but a measure
of excess or shortfalls in nominal gdp
and and for me that's
a measure of what macroeconomic policies
and so nominal gdp is simply you know
total dollar spending on final goods and
services so i know we really care about
real gdp that's you know what things we
can actually
eat and do and serve and provide but
nominal gdp is you know
you think of money times velocity kind
of going old monitor school here but
it's total spending and that's something
that macro policy can control and if
it's growing too rapidly then we know
policy's been too tight it's growing too
low
uh too slow relative to trend or however
you measure the some neutral path for it
and right now it's above
any kind of you know trend or or i use a
measure called the nominal gdp gap we
provided at the mercatus center you can
check it out but it's based on forecasts
drawing trends is fun but at some point
trends become i think misleading
especially the longer you go out sure so
it's important to base i think on
forecast and
no matter how you slice and dice it
right now nominal gdp or total aggregate
demand is above where it should be above
expectations above trend
which tells me then that you know the
fed and treasury fiscal policy have been
running the economy too hot so
just stepping back why do we have high
inflation i think it's both supply
shocks and i think
macro policy has been too loose
so i'm i'm curious because
you know
on a fundamental level
i think one of the reasons that that
monetary policy
has a hard time getting it right
is because of the dual mandate
and they're
inherently conflicting
aims for the fed and you know some would
say that the the fed abandoned its
inflation mandate in 2021 in favor of
its employment mandate
and i'm curious what your philosophy is
on
on that change to the federal reserve
act in 1978 whether that was
whether that's something there's there's
actually a bill in congress right now to
uh to roll that back to get rid of the
employment mandate and go go to where
the european central bank is and other
major central banks and have the
singular focus be on
on minimizing inflation well i would say
politically first that
i think everyone's going this direction
so
even the ecb recently updated its
framework so that it
it looks at making up for past mistakes
and although it's still technically a
price stability it is figuring it is
implicitly accounting for the you know
the business cycle of the
european economy but other places like
you look new zealand new zealand
it's one of the original pure inflation
targeters it now has a dual mandate and
i i think it's it's not surprising we've
come down this path and are likely to
stay here it's because of you know
democracy people people you know
politicians and their personal bankers
respond to the body politic and that's
why we have an independent central bank
but still they get appointed they're
still having dose of politics even in
central bank um in fact very heavy we
could talk about that too well you're
actually i mean i can
you're actually going to the next
you're literally stepping right into it
yeah but i i think i think it's probably
inevitable we end up something like a
dual mandate i think the best way to
deal with that though is
again not to sound like a broken record
but a nominal gdp target it's one target
it's it's dollar based so it's it's
nominal
um
it accounts for supply shock so if there
is a real
distortion on the rural side
just to be real brief here not a nominal
gdp target imagine the fed keeps demand
on a stable path okay well what would
happen if there's a supply shock supply
shock would temporarily raise inflation
and lower real gdp
nominal gdp
some of both of those would stay the
same so what it does it allows the fed
to see through supply shocks but also
keeps the fed making sure demand is not
growing too fast or too slow that's my
proposed solution to this it's going to
be here
stick to a nominal target but yes
clearly the the um average inflation
targeting framework
really put more emphasis on the maximum
employment side of the mandate
it did
and and i'm i'm curious uh
i'm curious about your views
if you can go back to your days at
treasury of the the now close links
between
uh the fed and treasury and i'm
wondering if you think that at some
point in our future that there'll be
another 1951
federal reserve treasury accord and
whether or not there'll be another kind
of formalized separation of the two to
be very explicit that the fed is an
independent institution well i i think
that is an important issue
i mean two way two points on that first
um
i worry about the fed's large balance
sheet not just because it's you know
footprint and the economy it's you know
we talked about overnight reverse repo
facility i mean one implication of that
is the fed's becoming a bigger and
bigger part of the repo market it's it's
the biggest counterparty and i find that
troubling but you know another
point about this is that the fed's
um
going back to the liability side of this
balance sheet it's becoming a bigger and
bigger public debt manager that's the
treasury's job but if you add up all the
liabilities on the fed's balance sheet
so add up all the reserves um so they're
about 3.8 trillion now
it was about 4 trillion and then
overnight reverse repo was about 1.7 if
we round up four and two or close to six
just under six trillion in government
liabilities that the fed is managing so
you know i the i believe the recent
numbers but you know the
total treasury debt is 22 trillion 23
the marketable portion
um
and the fed is you know managing six
trillion of that
that's a huge amount
that they
they should that should not be the fed's
preview that is definitely something
treasury so there's been proposals to
find ways to move those liabilities back
to the treasury and i think that's
important because as you know when the
fed manages six trillion with the
liabilities it's affecting the the you
know the mark the structure of the
government debt you know the decide
average duration
that's all affected by the fed and six
trillion you know a good chunk of that
and that's you know we
we have delegated that authority truth
treasury not the fed so i i worry
i i do think it's important maybe it'd
be a little bit of a different of the
you know
treasury record but that'd be one point
the other part is just politics are
creeping into the fed
and they feel increased pressure in fact
i was just talking to someone
who who worked at the fed for many years
and they had friends inside the fed and
they said look you know we spend so much
time
on
progressive agenda items and far less
time on
macroeconomic analysis
so i'll let you give my real my one that
really you know is going to make me
unpopular
with the left here but like let me give
you a good example climate change
now i i believe it's a real issue but i
believe congress is is the entity in
other government agencies to deal with
the epa
but congress in particular the fed is
not going to be a very good ep a
supercharged epa but there's more and
more pressure for it to do something it
already has two committees looking at
climate change one of them's
called well i'll just describe one of
them is dealing with kind of the the um
effect on banks like locally then
there's more of a
systematic review of the policy
and the fed recently joined this this
this network of central bankers for
greening of central banks
and
again i think climate change is a real
risk yes it may affect asset values down
the road
but this war with russia right there not
us but the russia ukraine war
should be a stark reminder there's
plenty of risk out there
that we don't know is going to happen i
mean the pandemic the russia ukraine war
we could have an asteroid hit
um there's slow moving disaster
population growth decline all these
things are could affect asset values but
we don't single them out
but we do single out climate change and
i just think it
singling out one area because it's
politically exceeding to do so is going
to undermine the fed's independence paul
tucker former central banker from the
bank of england i don't know if you ever
interacted with him in your days at the
fed but he has this great tome on on you
know
central bank independence and he makes
the point which i find very i think
convincing and i i try to apply it in my
thinking
and that is if if congress or in this
case parliament's going to delegate
authority to an agency
that agency needs to even
on a particular issue that agency needs
to
apply it in a way that there's
consensus in the body politics so for
example
congress is delegated and fed price
stability
most americans agree on price stability
right
over most most americans would agree
that's an important goal
america is divided on climate change now
maybe most i don't know what most
americans believe about climate change
but the the response to climate change
very divisive issue
and when you and paul's point is if you
have an agency deal with a very divisive
issue it's going to undermine its
independence and i just i worry
that this is going to backfire you know
right now it's it's climate change will
republicans take over is it going to be
you know funding the wall i mean i mean
it's going to swing one
right direction to the other and and
that's going to make it less of a
technocratic independent institution
well so
at some point
you have to recognize the elephant in
the room which i think that so few
people
uh understand and appreciate and it came
out in your most recent podcast and that
is what what i called and fed up which
you know in the book that i wrote what i
what i called the mit mafia and that is
the staff at
the federal reserve board
and how much power they exert over
the ability to
to stand up and say no no no wait we're
going in the wrong direction we need to
be independent
leadership needs a voice
whether you're talking about
people on the board
being kind of overwhelmed by the
staffers or if you're talking about
district bank presidents who are even
more marginalized uh but but
it seems like this the staff
increasingly is
dictating the dialogue and
in the background pushing the fed to be
more political i i've got the impression
that's less the case now i may be wrong
um let me give you some reasons for a
hope here so
um i know when jay powell came in
you know jay pal he's kind of an aw
shucks kind of guy very disarming
personality but he there was an article
or two written about how he
disempowered the barons at the board of
governors you know there's there are
these gatekeepers yeah the chiefs of
each section you can only as an
economist you can only go through them
and he kind of said no let's we're going
to stop that so
i think that's a refreshing change
the other thing again going back to the
little animal i was telling the story
there are many fed staffers on the
inside who who feel the pressure from
the woke progressive they want to do
macroeconomic analysis in fact i had
someone on the show you might watch
their paper a carol binder she's at
haverford college and then uh
christina paragon skinner she's at
wharton university pennsylvania
christina is a law professor and kerala
is a economics professor but they have a
paper they did where they went out and
they tracked
on the past few decades of research
from the regional banks and this is i
think motivated by
senator toomey's concern about the
regional banks are getting real
progressive and woke so they they track
their research and and really
fascinating if you go to their paper
they show these charts
of
the amount of research the share of
research being dedicated to like
inequality climate change
uh what a i forget a few other
progressive agendas
and it it's an increasing share of the
research output
so which means there's less being done
on traditional macro topics right
um so i mean
there probably is still some of what
you're saying but i would just say that
i think pal has been good
at least from that perspective and then
i would also say the staff themselves
are feeling the pressure
that this politicized environment so
that's i mean that that's actually
refreshing to hear you know one of my
mentors inside the fed was a guy by the
name of harvey rosenblum he was he was
at the fed for 40 years he was the
director of research under richard
fisher and as he was retiring after 40
years he'd started out in chicago i said
i said you know what's what's your main
takeaway and he said well
i wish that i would have i would have
guided my phd staff to do more research
on monetary policy and i went i don't i
don't understand and he said
well for a lot of them
you know they go off and do the research
that they want to do regardless of the
fact that they're in a in an institution
that is
mandated to to to safeguard the economy
with monetary policy uh so
and
and you know i'm i i had heard about
powell and and the barons
given who your favorite person is
somebody relayed to me um
recently that paul volcker used to make
the staff sit down at his at seminars
that explained why the phillips curve
was bunk so
i had to share that with you but he made
the stafford this is many many many
moons ago
but on that note who is your favorite
fed chair in history
i'm curious oh wow that's a tough one um
you know i'll go even though you know
things haven't gone perfectly i'd
probably have powell and volker tied
um i think
i think both of them have gone through
an excruciating a lot
very tough challenges they've been
through a lot
um
what i like about pal
is that he has some humility about him
he's also very politically smart
so
he had this statement i think it was a
wall street journal that he was going to
wear out the carpets and capitol hill as
soon as he became which is brilliant i
mean you know with all respect to ben
bernanke and janet yellen they're
academics right yep they didn't probably
they met with people but powell
understood the importance
and that's why he could survive both
democrats and republicans you know when
when trump was after him or when
elizabeth warren's after him he had a he
had a base of support right so yeah i
mean it it's a matter of public record
his daytime i mean no fed chair has been
up the hill as much as yeah
and i think you know
given we went through the pandemic
what we're doing now i mean there's
there's definitely some decisions i
would i would disagree on but i i think
given the alternatives given where we
could be i i think he's done relatively
well but paul volcker obviously is the
one who changed the direction of the
economy i mean i think fiscal policy
played a role too
you know there were tax reforms and
stuff in the 1980s that were important
as well
but you know you
paul volcker was a sheer force of
personality that has to be admired we
know that powell's going to get
reconfirmed handily
my question is
senator shelby recently asked him
pointedly
are you willing as paul volcker was are
you willing to put the united states
economy into a recession
and you know powell can't run around and
claim that the world is burning down
it's his job to not do that i get that
but when asked that that pointed of a
question he said i hope when history
writes the books the answer is yes
and i thought that that was a very
curious
i mean i i was proud that he said it um
but do you think
that he has an interval or do you think
he can put the u.s economy into
recession to get inflation even if it's
just i mean we're seeing to your point
we're seeing unloading times at the
docks come way off we're seeing activity
at
the ports come way down the supply chain
disruption is being undisrupted delivery
times are are coming way down so
a lot of things that are
that a lot of things that were said to
have been transitory are passing through
yeah that being said we know that
housing inflation is acting with a very
long lag
and that there are exogenous sources of
inflation right now that have really
complicated matters but do you think
powell can put the us economy into a
recession i think he will if necessary
um
i i i
i think you know before
you know even as late as 2021 2020 for
sure
the fed was still worried about what had
happened in the past decade which is low
inflation low rates
and and you know in some sense we all do
this we fight the last battle
i mean you know but now it's
now you know the last last battle it's
time to re-fight you know the 1970s
concern so i i think he he will it's not
going to be easy but just the amount of
political pressure i mean
who would have thought a few years ago
that inflation would be such a salient
political issue right i mean it's going
to kill the democrats here in the fall
um it's killing biden's approval rating
it's it's
you know in some ways it's it's a
it's a good check i mean i'll
like my car's in the table i think in
some ways this is a healthy dose of
medicine to remind us that the world
doesn't operate according to mmt
you know this is amen to that
well this is a this is a you know
they've gone awfully quiet now that
inflation is really high but i i think
i think we go through generational
swings where we forget what happened in
the past now i you know let me be very
clear i like the fed's new framework i
think it was taken to an extreme which
has led to this inflation but it had
some
the ability to to deal with low low
inflation like in the if we have that
again i think is useful
for me the struggle with the framework
is it's still an inflation target basin
and it's so confusing like right now
we're seeing as inflation caused by
supply side of demand side what we care
about is demand demand that is the fed
creating too much demand and again going
back to normal gdp targeting that's why
i wish the fed would go down there in
fact i think 2025 the fed's having
another review
they're going to update their framework
and uh i'm i'm hoping that you know
they'll move closer to nominal gdp
targeting but i guess going back to your
question i'm taking a long way there but
the
the idea that powell will do what's
necessary i think he will i think he's
pragmatic
um
he still as you know wants to engineer a
soft landing i just think that's harder
and harder by the day i think the
discussion has shifted um because of
russia ukraine and the dis but you
already saw confidence coming down prior
to that moment as it is and now we have
confidence at the lowest level in more
than a decade um
so
let's talk about
the the head of bank supervision let's
talk about
the tradition because i think that this
is uh underappreciated when you have a
cabinet appointee
as a president
it's it's kind of copacetic to have a
party line
um
vote
you can go 50 50 for somebody in your
cabinet because they're political
appoint appointees
tradition has it that that is not the
case
with federal reserve officials with
governors
and yet we look back we see that that
that brainerd had 63 votes
and that yellen was the only one that
came closer to the line with 56
votes in the senate
uh
and they're
they're they're both political animals
the both of them
but do you think that that that fed
appointees that fed nominees should be
held to a higher standard
uh than cabinet appointees when it comes
to getting a consensus vote
in congress because they are supposed to
be
a political
individuals who join the board
i know that was a really easy question
wasn't it
yeah
well let me answer it this way
i think the fed
the nomination process for the fed is
simply succumbing to the same
politicization forces that we see
everywhere else
and
you know if you're going to again put
someone on on the fed
and that person has a strong view on an
issue that evenly and roughly evenly
divides the country
what do you think is going to happen i
mean this is not the good the good old
days you're right there was more
civility but you know but in general
politics is less polarized we live in a
different environment different
era and i think
biden if you were smart would pick
someone who was less controversial i
mean he's had two big nominations you
know burned on him right uh salah
omorova and then sarah blumraskin so
both of them
were perceived whether fairly or not
they were perceived as you know more
radical
choices
and you know biden needs to pick someone
who's he's a democrat but they're
pragmatic you know just left of center
um otherwise
this is going to keep happening and you
know it didn't help
that the democrats kind of poisoned the
well over at the fdic
you know the the point he's over there
and i remember talking to some friends
who were on left of center on twitter i
was like you're going to come to regret
this like oh no no it was necessary we
got to make change now i'm like
there are norms out there for a reason
we want to preserve institutional you
know
integrity integrity
and doing that kind of short-sighted you
know reshuffling of power is is just
but again that's that's par for course i
mean you know things have been going
that direction so maybe we shouldn't be
surprised
but if you're a politic if you're a
president the smart thing to realize is
it's gonna be a bloody process so pick
someone you know
who can make it through that bloody
process not someone who's going to be
perceived
as radical
and just just as an aside i've never
seen so many candidates trying to be
pushed through together it's just
unheard of oh yeah that's a good point
i mean
in the beginning it was like buy one get
four free i was like what i don't i just
don't understand this and
i
i will tell you that that pat toomey is
one of my favorite people in the world
because he respects term limits and
one man has been able to do
so much something else that he insisted
on doing and i'm curious your view on
this is he insisted with the final
stimulus package that president trump
signed into law he insisted that the the
treasuries
off-balance sheet vehicles
for a credit and he was aiming mainly at
the municipal bond one but they that
they'd be switched off a but that they
could not be switched back on unless
there was a new unusual exigent
a new kind of emergency
that whoever the next treasury secretary
was wouldn't just be able to flip a
switch in the event that there was i
mean you you've seen the move index as i
have the move index is telling you that
there's there's credit risk bubbling up
in the system
well in response to that the law says
because of toomey the law says that that
janet airline cannot just flip the
switch back on
so
it comes back to your
it's a parallel to the standing repo
facility and the stigmatization
can the fed engineer again especially
without fiscal authorities helping them
and all that all the stimulus spending
what happens in credit and this is
similar to will powell put the economy
into recession you know what happens if
you can't turn those facilities back on
at treasury which i personally don't
think should exist as a matter of public
record well i
i agree with you your concern about
all these off-balance sheet entities i
mean i think congress should
decide you know ahead of time this is
again probably asking too much for
congress but in theory congress should
say hey
here here's a law which says this
authority turns on when x happens you
know or we're going to empower the fed
with you know very clearly thought out
um
you know
set of tools that can be
almost like an automatic stabilizer for
liquidity support when when certain
conditions are met that should be
something congress should create i mean
during the great depression that
congress created their refinance
corporation which kind of played it was
a fiscal authority outside of the fed
that was empowered to you know try to
save some banks
in in a productive manner now
that's the kind of direction i would
prefer if it's explicitly you know a law
by congress with that said the u.s has a
rich history of doing off-balance sheet
activity i mean when i when when 2020
was unfolding i'm like man look at all
these facilities and some of the
facilities i support but some of them
are cooling credit facilities and i said
you know i was like
congress is effectively pushing its
responsibility on the fed to do more and
more
and it's off balance sheet so it doesn't
get reflected in you know budget numbers
and then someone reminded me said david
david
take a deep breath we've been doing this
for years with the gscs
i mean it's nothing new it's just it's
the easy politically expedient thing to
do which is which is a fair point
um
with that said so what could the fed do
in a crisis going forward i mean other
than you know growing back to congress
the fed still has other facilities that
maybe indirectly could support you know
that particular market you know the fed
still can
the fed can still under invoke 13 3
powers and invoke some of the facilities
it has
i think the real
if there were a challenge i guess to to
invoking those
it would be more the the impact it has
on the fed's balance fed's balance sheet
is so large already right what happens
when it gets bigger and for the things
we talked about who's going to be
funding
our money market fund's going to step in
bank's going to who's next or corporate
treasury
yeah
i mean which would mean then the fed
would start maybe you know
buying directly in corporate
markets so
you know there's a whole interesting
conference a separate conversation what
does it mean to have a neutral footprint
in terms of asset purchases
um if i might just add real quick on on
this point so in the us
and in the uk the view is the fed should
only buy treasuries because you're just
swapping one government liability for
another from the consolidated government
balance perspective it's a wash so
that's neutral
in europe however they would say no no
no no
you're still
supporting government debt
disproportionately supporting government
debt which is going to affect its price
relative to other assets so you're not
being very neutral so the german model
which influences the ecb is
the the central bank should actually buy
a basket of assets that's representative
of whatever a typical
investor holds so that you're
just i know that's not such a thing as a
typical investor but just imagine on
average there's this typical investor
you want to mimic that basket that they
hold so that you're having less
distortions
and that's the european model but we
have the us uk model here
we do and we have a massive footprint
basically
that is credit easing in the
mortgage-backed securities market
oh yeah yeah and and if i could ask you
uh just
just to to make that my twitter
followers calm down
the fed is not growing its balance sheet
anymore and i get this all the time i'm
like mortgage-backed securities take a
long time to settle they're not
and yet people are watching the weekly
reports so closely uh but
i think i i think that there's
it's important for people like you to to
kind of distill the conspiracy theories
quantitative tightening when it happens
we're going to know yeah um you know the
fed
has over a trillion dollars in treasury
liabilities i haven't checked
mortgage-backed securities but over a
trillion dollars and
trillion dollars in treasury liabilities
that will mature within a year so
if the fed did nothing if if it allowed
assets to passively roll off
it could shrink pretty quickly
um
will it do that and we'll see so you
know on one hand
and what effect does qe have these large
scholastic purchases tabs i alluded to
earlier
you know there's this academic theory
which says it shouldn't make that much
difference other than maybe a signaling
channel
i'm not i guess i'm not a big supporter
at least in theory of the portfolio
balance channel
but there's a signaling channel i
acknowledge that but then when you look
at the plumbing side then i think it
does matter immensely as we talked about
the plumbing of the fed's operations
behind qe
i think are more important than maybe
some of the other things we typically
look at when we think about qe
one of the other
pleas that i get constantly on my feed
is why doesn't the fed just sell
long-maturity
bonds off of its balance sheet and
it's it's hard to explain but that the
idea is kind of voldemort within the
federal reserve system it's just not
done
uh
so
maybe maybe you could unpack that just a
tiny bit and then then we'll round up
well if we step back and look say
pre-2008 the fed's balance sheet does
permanently grow over time
um
so as you all you mentioned earlier
there's currency demand that's going to
grow there's bank reserves as the
economy grows the fed's balance sheet
has to permanently get larger just to
stay normal not just to avoid you know
now of course we're way beyond that but
um
this that's something to keep in mind
that it's you want to actually some of
that you want to keep so let me step
back post 2008
the fed was shrinking his balance sheet
and as you mentioned some of that that
balance sheet switched from reserves
into currency
and at that point the horse is out the
barn that's just that's the reality of
life so we couldn't shrink it back to
pre-2008 values and
there's a big difference now to be fair
the fed's balance sheet now is close to
9 trillion it was 4 trillion before so i
think there is some reduction that needs
to be done but the fed yes the fed is
going to be
hesitant to move aggressively
maybe legitimately given plumbing issues
given signaling channel
but i i do think they are eager
to shrink
um
for one reason we haven't touched i
think might be important here and that's
the political economy or the politics of
the fed's balance sheet
and i think this is going to be a big
deal going forward and i think this
might be if anything a biggest kind of
motivation
and i'm speculating here but i would say
an important motivation
and that is think of that 6 trillion we
talked about almost 6 trillion in
liabilities bank reserves and overnight
reverse repo facilities those earn
interest
the banks the money market funds now if
rates do start to go up as markets are
predicting
think how big of the payments banks are
going to get
and money market funds are going to and
gscs are going to get from the fed and
think how that's going to play out
politically
um you know i can imagine elizabeth
warren is losing herself over there yes
as well as it's a bad image now
technically if
if if banks and money market funds are
getting paid the same rate they would
get at treasury it really it's not
fundamentally different they're just
holding treasu fed liabilities but if
the rate is higher than say treasuries
are offering it is indeed a subsidy to
them but no matter what it is at the end
of the day it looks awful oh yeah um and
and it and it just opens up the fed's
balance sheet as an attractive piggy
bank in general
the fed's balance sheet
seems to be a free lunch you know we can
tap it and do things you know
and i mean
you know in the end jp morgan chase i
mean that was a major line item in their
on on their profit statement it was just
ioer and that and you're right the
optics are very damning they're toxic
yeah so they're i think
they know this and they need to they
want to shrink because i mean nine
trillion i mean again
six trillion in terms of like
liabilities you have to pay but it's
it's gonna get it's gonna get intense um
pretty soon if they don't shrink it
meaningfully it's it's even that four
trillion dollars it's you know rates
start going up it's the same discussion
on federal debt federal debt rates go up
bigger interest payments you know sure
same thing with the fed
smaller number but just as
poor in terms of optics exactly i
couldn't agree more um well before i let
you go i i have to i have to say now i
understand because you told me that you
started off your life uh
as a child of missionaries now i
understand why you have a bible verse on
your twitter feed
and i actually i mean my my mother
always she always guides me to a
particular psalm so you've got you've
got micah on yours but uh but i i just
have to say now i i kind of get it
when did you come back to the state i'm
curious
well i'll date myself here
but i came back in 1982.
okay so we were there from 1976 to 1982
so i lived through it like we lived in
south africa i lived through apartheid
um wow and my dad actually worked for a
church
that itself was divided because of
apartheid in south africa so my my dad
actually worked his work was to work
with you know the the the black south
africans but he traveled to other parts
of africa too so it was a real you know
this is a kid and i was really young
back then it was still i was very aware
things were messed up over there come
back to the u.s things are better
what does it take to change
well exactly and i i'm going to keep i'm
going to keep the verse pulled up and
and share it with my mother who's she's
she's a great she's a great study of the
bible uh
and and i will hope that maybe in a
year's time we can come back together
and
revisit what the plumbing looks like you
know on the other side of this the
beginning of this massive fed campaign
uh well
yeah i know
hopefully no recession between now and
then but maybe
we will we will see we will see you know
what but we'll we'll see which curve was
right let's put it that way there you go
i'll send you a copy of my book you send
me a t-shirt how's that okay okay thank
you so much for your time i really
appreciate it thank you for having me on
your show